- Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for making
the trek to Mandalay Bay
and welcome to our session,
"Bridging the Gap from
Prototype to Production".
Over the last year,
we have started seeing AI agents
transition into autonomous systems
that can reason, plan, and adapt
in pursuit of user-defined goals,
completing tasks on behalf
of humans or other systems,
things like compiling research,
remediating infrastructure issues,
or even generating full stack applications
from a single prompt.
The advent of reasoning
models, agent frameworks,
and open source protocols
like model context protocol
have made it easier than
ever to prototype agents.
And as a result,
we are seeing an explosion
of agent prototypes
across both startups and enterprises.
But when we look at which ones
actually made it make into production,
the number is in low single digits.
Quick show of hands,
how many of you have built
or experimented with an agent
in the last six months?
That's a lot.
Now keep your hands up if that
agent made it into production
and is running reliably today.
See that drop off?
That's the story we
are here to talk about.
We are still in the early
innings of the agent era.
There's enormous excitement,
enormous potential,
but the value only comes
when those agents operate safely at scale.
I'm Vivek Singh.
I lead product management
for Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
I'm joined today by Mark Roy,
tech lead for agentic AI at AWS,
and Sarbashis Das who's the
GenAI tech lead at Ericsson.
Today, we'll cover the key
challenges that developers face
in moving their agent
prototypes to production
and how Bedrock AgentCore
provides developers
the building blocks to cross the prototype
to production chasm.
We also have a few demos for you
to show AgentCore in action,
and then Sarbashis will cover
how Ericsson is leveraging AgentCore
to power agentic AI innovations.
So let's get into it.
AI agents are autonomous systems.
So even a basic one requires
multiple moving parts
such as orchestration, tool execution,
state management, and error handling.
That's a lot of wiring to get right.
And here is where frameworks
like LangGraph, Strands
Agents, and CrewAI help.
They provide ready-made abstractions
for behaviors like multi-step planning,
coordination between different sub-agents,
tool and vocation.
That means developers
no longer have to start
everything from scratch.
They can focus on defining
the agent's behavior
while the frameworks take care
of the lower level plumbing.
So using these frameworks,
you can spin up a coding assistant,
a customer support bot,
or a sales agent in a few days.
But moving that same
prototype to production
with thousands of users,
reliability requirements,
lead compliance requirements,
that's a completely different ballgame.
Let's make that concrete.
Imagine you build an agent,
let's call it sales assist,
that helps your sales
reps close deals faster.
It answers product questions,
it pulls customer history from Salesforce,
it drops personalized emails,
and it can even suggest next
steps based on prior deals.
You can get that prototype up and running
for one sales rep locally in a few days.
Now, imagine deploying
that across 10,000 reps
in five different countries,
each with dozens of daily conversations,
each agent accessing Salesforce,
confluence, DocuSign,
your internal pricing APIs,
all while acting under a
rep's individual permissions.
That's where the real work begins.
Let's unpack what makes that
transition so challenging.
When you try to scale
something like sales assist,
four categories of challenges emerge fast.
Your performance, scalability,
security, and governance.
Before you even think about scale,
the agent has to be responsive,
reliable, and accurate.
It has to be able to reason well,
reliably call multiple
tools to take action,
remember pertinent facts
from prior interactions.
For example, sales assist might ace a demo
with one or two tools,
but in production it's
tens or hundreds of tools,
each with its own auth,
schema, rate limits,
and unpredictable failures.
Turning all of those
into uniform reliable
MCP'S compatible tools
becomes a massive engineering challenge.
Secondly, LLMs are stateless,
but agents are not.
So sales assist must
remember the deal history.
It must remember pertinent facts
from prior customer interactions
such as the quote it gave
to the customer last week.
Without a proper memory layer,
the agent will lose context,
misremember things, and can
even hallucinate the past state.
And without continuous evaluations
for things like correctness
and helpfulness,
the agent performance may
even drift in production
leading to widespread customer impact.
So performance is not about picking
a bigger and better model,
it's a system around the model,
the continuous evaluation,
the tool integration,
the persistent memory
that keep the agents
reliable and consistent.
After performance, the
real challenge scale.
Sales assistant production
means thousands of concurrent agents,
each making multiple tool calls,
running long workflows,
and handling sensitive
customer data at the same time.
So you need a secure, resilient,
and elastic runtime
that can scale up during peak workloads,
scale down when idle,
keep each agent session isolated,
maintain state during long running
multi-step reasoning workflows,
and quickly recover from failures
like API timeouts or service disruptions
when it's calling multiple
different tools and services.
Then comes security.
Agents act on behalf of humans.
So every action must respect
fine-grained identity and access controls.
If Sarah in Enterprises
is using sales assist,
it should see a list of
her Fortune 500 accounts.
But when Tom in Startup
does it, he shouldn't.
The sales assist shouldn't
see the Enterprise accounts.
That's per user identity,
not shared credentials.
And doing that securely across
thousands of agent sessions
requires deliberate design.
Finally, you need
visibility and guardrails
to know what each agent is doing
and to control unsafe
actions before they happen.
If a D goes sideways,
can you audit what data
sales assist accessed,
what email it sent, what
pricing it suggested?
Additionally, you need a way
to enforce your business
rules in real time.
For example, never share
unannounced features,
never discount over 20%.
So governance isn't something
that you bolt on later.
It has to be built in in your
application from day one.
And doing all of these things
essentially means building
a distributed enterprise scale system
that can handle thousands
of concurrent sessions,
millions of tool calls,
adhere to strict latency and
reliability requirements,
all while leaving very
little room for error.
And that's the difference
between a prototype and
a production system.
And right now, developers
have to do significant
undifferentiated heavy lifting
in building all of these pieces
for a combination of a framework,
model, and a set of tools.
And as your business case evolves
and you want to leverage newer models,
newer frameworks, and newer tools,
you start all over again.
And that is what's slowing
down organizations right now
in realizing their agent equation.
To address these challenges,
we launched Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
It's a generally available service.
We launched it earlier this year.
It's an agentic platform
that provides a complete set of services
purpose-built to build,
deploy, and operate
highly performant agents
securely and at scale.
Let's look into some
of the key characteristics of AgentCore.
First, AgentCore helps
you optimize time to value
because you don't have to
manage any infrastructure.
All AgentCore services
are completely serverless
and you pay for what you use.
For example, if you're
using AgentCore Runtime,
you only pay for the
active compute and memory
that your agent consumes.
In fact, you don't even have
to pay for the I/O wait time,
which is the time your agent spends
waiting to get responses back from LLMs
and different tool calls.
And in most of the agentic session,
I/O wait could make it up to 60 to 70%
of the overall agent session time.
Secondly, AgentCore was built
with flexibility in mind.
Each AgentCore service
is completely modular,
so you can use them together
or you can use them independently.
And each AgentCore service
works with any framework
or model out there.
So if you built your agent using LangGraph
or Cloud Agent SDK,
or if your agent is using
OpenAI models or Gemini models,
you can still use any of
the AgentCore primitives
with your agent.
And finally, AgentCore
provides the controls,
the access management,
and the observability,
which are crucial for
enterprise deployments.
So overall with AgentCore,
you can accelerate
prototypes into production
with the scale, reliability, and security,
which are critical to
real world deployments,
eliminating months of infrastructure work.
Now, let's look into
some of the key services
that Agent Core offers.
First, to build highly performant agents,
AgentCore offers memory
that helps developers
build context of their agents.
It automatically extracts
and stores short-term memory
across multi-term user interactions,
as well as long-term memory patterns
such as semantic memory
and user preferences
across longer horizon
and multiple sessions.
Gateway enables you to
compose your tools and agents
across your ecosystem
into a single MCP server interface
that you can then expose
to your agent remotely.
With Gateway, you can combine
different tool sources
from your REST APIs to
your Lambda functions
to your existing MCP servers
into one unified interface
without managing multiple tool connections
or implementing any integrations.
AgentCore also provides
fully managed tools
that are essential to
most agentic workflows.
Code interpreter enables agents
to securely generate and execute code
in isolated environments,
and browser enables agents to interact
with web applications at scale.
Then to deploy and scale agents,
AgentCore provides a secure
and serverless runtime
that is purpose built to
host agents as well as tools,
and agents and tools could
be built using any framework,
any protocol, whether it's
MCP or A2A or any model.
AgentCore identity simplifies
agent identity and access management,
allowing agents to securely
access AWS services
and third party services
on behalf of users with
preauthorized consent.
And we also launched policy today,
this was announced in Matt's keynote,
which provides you real
time deterministic controls
over how agents interact
with your enterprise tools and data.
And you can define these
policies in natural language.
For example, block all
reimbursement requests,
which are over a thousand dollars,
and these policies are
evaluated and enforced
in real time in milliseconds
so that every agent action is operating
within the boundaries or
policies that you have specified.
And finally, to operate trustworthy agent,
we have observability that
provides rich visualization
into each step of the agent workflow,
as well as operational metrics
like token count latency
via unified dashboards.
It also emits the data like
logs, metrics, and traces,
and open telemetry compatible format
so you can plug it into the
monitoring tool of your choice
such as CloudWatch, Datadog,
Langfuse, and LangSmith.
And we also launched evaluations today,
which is a new AgentCore service
that helps developers continuously inspect
the quality of agent behavior
so that you can catch issues
before they cause
widespread customer impact.
Overall with AgentCore,
you get everything you need
to take your agents from
prototype through production
built on the AWS foundation
that customers already trust.
Now, I'm gonna hand it over to Mark
to go all layer deeper into these services
and show you a few demos
of how they work together.
- Thank you, Vivek.
(audience applauding)
Great introduction to AgentCore
and super excited to be here
for my eighth re:Invent.
My name is Mark Roy.
I'm with, do we go to
the wrong slide here?
Sorry, I might've hit the wrong button.
My name is Mark Roy, I am with AWS,
and I'm a global tech lead for Agentic AI.
And although you may think
I'm only 29 years old,
I've actually been building
for about 30 years now.
So Vivek talked a lot
about the chasm of production readiness.
I really love that term.
I'm wondering who here,
after that description,
feels like they're in that chasm
of production readiness already?
Anyone out there?
Okay, not too many hands.
But let me tell you, it is real.
For the last two years,
I've been working with
hundreds of customers
trying to build and deploy agents
and get real business value.
And I see three things
showing up every time.
One, great looking prototypes,
amazing capability, looks great,
compelling business value
that everyone's excited about,
all the potential,
and then months,
and usually quarters of heavy lifting
and pain and suffering in between.
So for the next 15 minutes,
I'll drill down into what
are those real challenges,
and I'll go one level deeper on AgentCore
and explain how these
services help you solve
those compelling challenges.
So with that, we've got a lot to cover.
So buckle up and let's jump in.
Let me start
with the very most common
and compelling challenge,
and that is where am I gonna run my agent?
I can't run my agent on my laptop
and just share that out to users.
So you're an agent builder and
you're thinking this through.
You've got pressure to
deliver some real value here.
You know that your agent is
gonna be used by 10,000 users.
You need to ship it now.
You've got a security officer
breathing down your neck saying,
"You've gotta make sure
this thing isn't going
to do the wrong things."
And for most of you,
you probably have got a platform team
you're working with as well,
and they're thinking
beyond your one agent.
They're dealing with
multiple different teams.
And guess what?
You're using LangGraph,
there's some other teams using CrewAI,
other teams using OpenAI,
and it's a bit of a mess.
And guess what?
If you look at across
these business units,
they've got a thousand use cases lined up.
So you've got a big dilemma here,
how am I gonna do this
at scale and securely
and not spend the next year getting ready?
So that's where AgentCore runtime steps in
and gives you the first major
component of your platform.
Runtime, lets you use
any framework, any model,
host your agent securely and at scale.
You can scale from zero to
thousands of concurrent sessions.
It comes built in with the
ability of the host MCP
to use A2A for agent interoperability,
OTEL for observability,
OAuth for security.
All of these things help
get you that time to value
where you can focus on building agents
and not building infrastructure.
Another key point here
is that although you're
probably working on,
let's say an intelligent chat experience,
that's kind of usually the first step,
there's a lot more out there.
There's voice agents,
there's long running, deep research,
there's large payloads to worry about.
This complicates what am
I gonna do about hosting.
It's not as simple as just
popping it into a Lambda.
That sales assistant
that Vivek talked about?
Let's say it's a multi-agent system.
You've got one agent
running with Claude SDK,
using Claude models,
another one using
LangGraph and GPT models,
maybe a third one using CrewAI and Gemini
with strands agent on top
of it doing orchestration
using Bedrock models.
All of this can be done
out of the box with runtime
and literally it's just four lines of code
to take an existing agent
and make it ready for AgentCore runtime
and then you can deploy it to the cloud
and it's ready to scale and
it's ready to be secure.
A2A built in? No problem.
You've got full interoperability there.
And if you want to host MCP servers,
you can pop your tools into
AgentCore runtime as well.
So I talked about security.
I'm not a security expert.
I'm kind of glad about that on some days.
When you're building agents,
you're using agents
because you want them to be
a little bit more autonomous,
you're not wanting to build
a hard coded traditional application.
Now what about when you're dealing
with sensitive information?
That's my social security number there.
Don't grab it, please.
You might be giving out credit scores.
You're doing very sensitive transactions.
And while your agent's
being used by one user,
there might be another user
doing something similar
with also sensitive data.
So I've got a question for you.
Who here, raise your hands high,
is ready to stand with
their security officer
and say they're a hundred percent sure
that those conversations are secure?
We've got one guy in the front row.
I wanna talk to you.
This is a huge challenge.
This, for me as a builder,
this is where I wake up with a cold sweat.
How am I gonna deal with this?
AgentCore runtime does
this out of the box.
Secure session isolation
for no coding involved.
It's just there.
Safely execute those conversations,
there's no risk of leaving
temporary files lying around,
no risk of getting permission escalations,
all taken care of for you.
You get multiple concurrent
sessions, no problem.
When the sessions are done,
poof, they're gone.
This is using our micro VM architecture
so it's not just a
container level isolation,
it's literally a micro VM
that ensures that this is going to work
and it does so at scale
and with low latency.
This is something that
I wouldn't recommend
trying to build on your own.
Okay, problem number one,
let's put a check box on that.
I think hosting AgentCore has
a pretty good story there.
What's the second biggest problem?
In my mind, agents, you know,
what separates maybe a toy agent
from closer to a real world agent,
real business values,
is is it able to learn?
Is it able to remember?
Is it able to improve?
How do you make that happen?
So first of all,
your agent better remember
what's been discussed
over the last few
minutes of a conversation
and then ideally it's
remembering what happened
in the last few months as well.
So that's called memory for an agent
and it better work reliably.
So even if the agent
needs to be restarted,
you better still have that there
and it better be secure as well.
And yes, you could build this on your own.
Do it yourself memory.
A lot of people out here
have probably tried it.
Wouldn't necessarily recommend it,
but with AgentCore,
you get a memory component out of the box.
So what does that mean?
Pick your favorite framework again
and just plug in AgentCore memory.
When you've got that,
your events, your conversations
feed right into short term memory.
It's got low latency, it's got security,
it's there for you to
have good conversations.
More exciting than that
is automatic memory extraction
into long-term memory.
What does that mean?
All of these conversations
get fed into a process
that runs behind the scenes
and extracts knowledge.
It extracts facts.
It summarizes conversations.
It even identifies
episodes as of yesterday.
We've got episodic memory now built in
and it will actually look across episodes
and reflect and get insights.
All of these get put into
what's called long-term memory.
And this long-term memory
can be easily plugged into your agent.
So now, instead of your agent
having this long list of conversations
that it's trying to take advantage of,
you can selectively pull
out long-term memory,
manage your context,
and make your agent
learning from the past.
And that's hyper-personalization.
And that's, again,
making really a real world
experience for your customers
and doing so fully manage,
serverless, secure,
and plugging into any framework.
Okay, so two check boxes.
We've got memory, we've got runtime.
What's the next big challenge?
To me, an agent is pretty useless
unless it can take action.
You've heard Matt Garman and Andy Jassy
say data is your differentiator,
and really that's true.
You could just use an off the shelf LLM
and get generic answers.
That's not gonna take you too far.
Your agent needs your data,
your APIs, your services,
and it needs your APIs
to take action as well.
That's the power.
So why is that so difficult?
Well, we've got cool things
like model context protocol
that showed up late last year
and is now used everywhere.
But how do you put those
MCP servers together
and how do you integrate
with all of your existing capabilities?
That's a lot of heavy lifting.
That's a lot of time, a lot of wrapping.
And how do you make that secure as well?
All of these things add
up to a lot of work.
So how does AgentCore help?
We've got something called Gateway
that automatically lets you
map those existing resources
and surface them as agent-ready tools.
So it exposes those APIs as MCP
and those MCP tools plug in
to Strands, and CrewAI, LangGraph,
whatever you're using, securely.
Let's look at a little
bit more closely here.
So Gateway, you can create
as many of these Gateways
as you'd like.
When you create a Gateway,
you can then add targets to that Gateway.
So add a bunch of API end points in there,
maybe throw in a few Lambdas,
get a couple of existing MCP
servers that have been built
or maybe third party ones,
and now you've got a Gateway
and you can hand that
Gateway to an agent builder
and say these are your tools.
Or you could have multiple of them,
they can discover different Gateways.
But basically, now you've
got agent ready tools
securely at scale to
plug into your agents.
Massive boost in time to value here.
Last cool thing on Gateway.
So you started with maybe a lack of tools.
You can easily get into a situation
where you've got too many tools,
hard to believe,
but pretty quickly you can see hundreds
or maybe thousands of tools.
And guess what happens
if you give a thousand
tools worth of MCP metadata
to your agent?
You don't wanna know.
It's not very pretty.
We have a built-in search.
So instead of handing all
300 tools in this case,
we give you a built-in semantic search.
So as you add tools,
they're automatically indexed.
You can call this MCP search capability.
Now you can do dynamic tool selection.
Instead of doing 300 tools,
give a handful of tools that
are built for that context.
Now you've got faster,
cheaper, and more accurate.
It's pretty rare to get a triple play here
but faster, cheaper, and more accurate
all from doing semantic search.
Okay, there's more.
So today, in the keynote from Matt,
as Vivek mentioned,
we introduced Policy
for AgentCore Gateway.
What's the big deal here?
So you can give permission for
who can access the Gateway,
who can access tools,
and you can have requested tool calls
and then which ones are allowed.
But what you really want
is something a little bit more granular
because what's happening here
is your agent has more autonomy
and you're balancing the
need for that innovation
with the need for control.
You don't wanna risk
getting on the front page
of the Wall Street Journal
with an agent doing a hundred
million dollar mistake.
So you wanna not trust your
agents to do the right thing.
You don't wanna trust your developers
to code up the right controls.
So with policy,
you're able to intercept
every single tool call
and apply policies that your
administrators can put in place
and attach to these Gateways.
It applies those policies
on the fly with low latency
and it does so in a way where
you can define these policies
in natural language
and they're verifiably
correct, verifiably enforced,
and it's deterministic.
So although your agent
is non-deterministic,
which is a good thing,
enforcing policies needs
to be deterministic
and that's what these
policies end up doing for you.
Of course, we've got observability
because you wanna know which
policies were enforced,
why they were enforced,
why do they get denied,
why do they get allowed
and be able to audit that.
And then I clicked one too many times.
So this is keeping your
agents in their lane,
keeping them inbounds while
still allowing innovation.
Okay, great.
We've got a couple of
built in tools as well.
So beyond just using Gateways
to get access to your MCP tools,
what about the power of
LLMs to generate great code?
Why not be able to plug
that into any agent
and make it an instant data analyst?
So here I'm saying in
that sales assist app,
how are my accounts doing?
So it can go grab some data,
but are LMS good at analyzing
large amounts of data?
Not necessarily.
They're a lot better at generating code
and now you've got a secure sandbox
that you just plug in as a tool
and your agent says, "Okay,
I know where to run this."
And you've got great results,
you can generate visualizations,
whatever you need actually
that the agent can generate on its own.
Secondly, although I mentioned earlier
a lot of nice APIs, data sources,
who here has a few legacy applications?
Maybe they're built five years ago.
Maybe 25 years ago.
They're still running
mission critical processes.
So we're not gonna reinvent those
in order to build an agent.
Why not use a browser and
automate access to those?
LLMs are great now at
interpreting screenshots.
And then you can have your
agent click at a certain field,
navigate to a different screen,
scroll down, scroll up,
copy the data into another field,
all of this possible.
We give you a headless browser.
You just plug it in as a tool
and you're off and running.
Okay, now let's quickly cover
three cross-cutting concerns.
First one is security.
It's all well and good to
come up with a great agent,
but there's table stakes here.
It's got to be secure.
And this is a challenging problem,
user talking to an app,
talking to an agent,
talking to another agent,
talking to tools that are
internal and third party tools.
You better get that right.
You can't afford to let the wrong user
get access to the data or
take the wrong actions.
So this is pretty difficult.
An AgentCore built into
runtime and gateway
takes care of inbound and outbound off.
On the inbound side,
you use whatever identity
provider you'd like,
maybe it's Microsoft Entra,
maybe it's Ping or Okta or Auth0,
plug that in and we take
care of who is the user
and how are they allowed
to use this agent.
On the outbound side, we can say,
is this user allowed to, using this agent,
get access to these tools?
And we plug in again on this side
with your credential providers.
You need Salesforce data.
You want ServiceNow or
Workday, JIRA, whatever it is.
There's either an API key
or an OAuth credentials,
maybe IAM in some cases.
We automatically let you configure those
as outbound providers
and then we make sure that
there's secure access end to end
on behalf of a user or on
behalf of an agent autonomously.
This is super important,
and please don't try
to do this one at home.
Don't try to do this one yourself.
It's scary complicated under the hood.
I've tried to make it look
pretty easy right here.
Another table stakes piece of
the puzzle is observability.
Never trust your agents.
Never put an agent into production
without being able to know
exactly what it's doing.
You've got to be able to go back
and find out exactly what it did.
Here's the request.
Here's the plan put together.
here's the steps that it took.
Maybe it redirected and
tried something else.
This is the inputs that
it passed to the tool.
This is what it got back.
Maybe it got back an error and it retried.
You need every bit of that.
Auditors are gonna come in.
Legal's gonna come in.
Why did this agent do this?
You've gotta be able to
have full observability.
We've got that across
all of these services.
We also give you dashboards
so you can easily see
not only typical metrics
like latency, error rates, and so forth.
You can see the end-to-end visualization,
a hierarchical timeline,
the full trajectory,
the inputs, the outputs, it's all there.
And in case you were wondering,
yes, we have open telemetry,
so if you want to use Dynatrace
or Datadog or Langfuse,
anything that you'd like, go for it.
Okay, last cross-cutting concern,
arguably the most important one so far.
Drum roll, please.
How do you know how good your agents are?
You've got to be able to measure
are they doing the right thing, right?
So this includes are they being safe?
Are they being responsible?
Are they being polite?
Do they have the right tone?
Are they giving back the right answers?
Are they making the right tool calls?
Are they passing the right parameters?
If you don't know the answers to these,
you're not doing a good enough job
for mission critical agents in production.
So in today's keynote,
we introduced AgentCore evaluations.
So what does that do?
So in under a minute,
you can go to the console,
pick your agent,
pick a set of metrics
that you want to turn on,
say where your traces are coming from,
turn on a sampling rate,
and then say go.
Any traffic that shows up in that agent
is gonna get automatically evaluated.
So AgentCore evaluations
will evaluate each of those
metrics on those traces
and give you scores.
And then not only will give
you a number or a label,
but it'll say why.
So why did it decide
that that was the score?
You'll see the reasoning
and that's all logged.
You'll get dashboards
and you can even do on demand evaluations.
So this is huge, critical,
and it was launched today in
public preview in AgentCore.
So this is the entire AgentCore platform.
It'll probably get bigger
and better over time,
but this is where it stands today.
And as Vivek mentioned,
you can pick and choose here.
These are composable services.
Decide which ones you're
having challenges with,
kick the tires on that,
integrate what you need,
use any framework, any
model, OAuth, OTEL, A2A, MCP.
All of the right acronyms are there.
So let's see a quick demo here
and then I'll bring you
Sarbashis from Ericsson
to dive in even further.
So here's the scenario.
I've said any framework, any model,
and I've said A2A,
but if you're not sure
if you really believe that that's true,
let's see it in action.
So in this example,
I've got an orchestrator
using Google ADK and Gemini.
You can see a couple of subagents,
one using Strands and Bedrock models,
another one using OpenAI and GPT-4,
and they're communicating using A2A.
And are you gonna boot me
off the stage, Precious?
Am I running too far?
Okay, I'll be done in about two minutes.
So we're using A2A.
We're using AgentCore
Gateway to access tools.
We've got memory and observability,
and let's keep going here.
Here's the UI.
We've got a JavaScript UI on the left.
We're showing you access
to A2A agent cards.
I'm handing it a task.
I'm asking it a question.
It's actually delegating
that to one of the sub-agents
that's using a different framework,
different model, uses A2A to get there.
It comes back with an answer.
I'll scroll ahead here.
Too far, sorry.
I don't like this laptop.
Let's see.
Oh man, isn't this great?
My apologies.
Okay, it's not gonna cooperate with me.
So we are using A2A to
have a conversation,
it's using multiple of those servers.
This is at the end here,
we're showing AgentCore memory as well.
So we're browsing,
we're showing you the short term memory,
the detailed conversations were tracked
showing you the long-term memory
where it learned some facts
and was able to surface those.
So with that,
let me hand it off to
Sabarshis from Ericsson
to talk about AgentCore.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Mark.
Hello, everyone.
You just heard about AgentCore
and how it bridges the gap
between proof of concept to production.
Now I'm going to show you how
this looks like in practice.
My name is Sabarshis Das.
I am a principal data scientist
and tech lead at Ericsson.
Within Ericsson, we are building
a number of agentic solution
across different areas,
and today I'm going to show
you one of our agentic solution
that reduces our network
engineers research time
from days to minute.
Before that, let me give you
some context about Ericsson.
If you think about global connectivity,
Ericsson is at the heart of it.
Right now, as I speak to you,
50% of the 5G traffic throughout the world
passes through the
technology that we build.
With such a scale, it comes complexities.
The question is that how do
we keep our network engineer
efficient in such a complex environment?
In reality, our network
engineers were trapped
in knowledge silos.
Let me explain.
A network engineer working on his features
need to look into thousands
of different documents
just to get to understand what
this feature is all about.
And then they need to find out
what exactly this has been implemented
in our millions of lines of code base
that is distributed on hundreds
of different subsystems.
You can imagine this takes days.
Not because the work is hard
but the information is fragmented,
the knowledge is isolated.
I can imagine that many
of you have also seen this
in your organization.
Our goal here is to fuse the information
across the different knowledge silos
to make a unified
understanding of the system.
How to do that?
Here is our solution.
We have created a
three-layered architecture
to eliminate the knowledge silos.
As you can see at the bottom layers,
we have industry standards,
we have our code base,
we have product information.
These are all fragmented information.
We need to process this document
in a way that it is ready to
consume to the next layer,
the knowledge layer.
That's why we have developed
advanced data processing pipeline.
In the advanced data processing pipeline,
we fetch the data across
different knowledge silos,
pass through GenAI
pre-processing pipeline.
The goal for the GenAI
pre-processing pipeline is to fetch,
is to process the data, clean the data,
and also the key is to extract information
from different modalities.
Once it is done,
it's stored the data to
different AWS storage,
depending on what data type.
It can be AWS Bedrock knowledge base
or it can be a graph database.
Once the data is ready,
it fed to the next layer
called knowledge layer.
This knowledge layer
consists of three component
as you can see.
We have a specialized agents.
These are agents that are
experts you can think about
in different areas.
So we are running a number
of these type of specialized agents.
Second, we have specialized model.
These models are specialized
in a sense that we have
trained those model
with our in-house data
and also the code base.
And the next part are
the developer's tools.
These are the tools our
network engineers uses
on a daily basis.
The knowledge layer is
connected on the top
with an orchestration layer
where the agentic
orchestration takes place
and communicate through
the knowledge layer
using MCP protocol.
The key here,
we are not just connecting different tools
in this layer architecture,
instead we are enabling
system comprehension,
the system that understand
the whole workflow
of our network engineer.
Let me show you how
these systems looks like
when you deploy this on
production using AgentCore.
So this is our architecture
that is deployed on AgentCore.
Our network engineer
interact with the system
using natural language,
just like asking a
question to your colleague,
that there very commonly one
question people are asking
that what is a HARQ timer.
Any of you have any
knowledge about HARQ timer?
Could you raise your hand?
I can imagine that this
is a very specific,
telecom specific query questions.
So then this next step
is the Amazon queue developers
or the front end.
These are the agentic system
that basically interprets the queries
and try to identify what
specialized knowledge needed
to answer this question.
And based on that, it request
securely through the Gateway
to different specialized agents
that are deployed on AgentCore runtime.
AgentCore runtime gives us the flexibility
to deploy any framework,
any open source framework on this,
and these are serverless.
So in this example you can
see that we have 3GPP agent,
which is an expert in telecom standards.
We have code generation agent.
This is an agent that
help our network engineer
to generate code.
This agent specially powered
by in-house trained LLM.
Ericsson builds its own ASICs
and the architecture is just
a proprietary information
of the self-coating models
that is available today
is not aware of those information.
And then another example,
you can see the RAN system design agent,
which is an expert in designing the system
and as well as how we are configuring
within Ericsson context.
All these agents sits on in
strong knowledge foundation
as you can see on the bottom
part in the knowledge layer
and that has been created
using advanced data processing.
The key here that all these
agent that you can see
running on these AgentCore runtimes,
they do not work insolation.
Instead they collaborate with each other.
They shared the context
and they build their insight
based on each other's finding.
We are also leveraging
other AgentCore services
that makes this architecture
enterprise-ready.
For example, AgentCore observability
gives us the flexibility
to check at a granular level
how our specialized agent behave and why.
The identity also gives us a secure way
to keep access control.
Now, the question is that
how our network engineers
uses this system.
So you can see that
generally, as I mentioned,
they interact with natural language.
So this is an example question.
Explain how HARQ timer works
and elaborate in downlink design.
Identify and list the main
implementation component
in the code.
As you can see, this has multiple parts
asking about HARQ timers
and also implementation in the code.
As you can imagine that
a typical RAG solution
is not going to give you the answer
that our network engineer is asking for.
In our case with our agentic solution,
first, the RAN system
design agent kicked in
and it is a deep research agent.
What it does is it looked for hundreds
of different documents,
try to identify what is this HARQ timer,
and generate a deep research output.
And this deep research output
then fend to the next agent
is our AI code search.
AI code search able to find
out from natural language
where exactly it has been implemented
by looking at our millions
of lines of code base.
Once it is done,
it pass on the output to the
next Ericsson silicon LLM.
And this is also another
in-house trained LLM
capable of explaining the code.
As you can see,
all these agents is not
going to work in isolation
but they collaborate
and share the context.
At the end, the network engineer
will not just get a chat bot response.
Instead a system level understanding
from the theory to the architecture
to the implementation in the code
and all connected how the features works.
Let me show you quickly
two example of the output.
So this is an output generated
from our deep research agent.
As you can see that it's a very
comprehensive documentation
and also it generate the images on the fly
that helps our network engineer
to understand the concept easily.
This is another one
where our Ericsson silicon
LLM explain the code
and you can see that it's not explaining
just a syntactical explanation.
Instead it's try to connect
it with the concept.
Now, imagine a network engineer
started working on these features
have to do all these things manually.
Looking at the features like
a deep research on that,
finding the implementation
in the code base and connect.
And this takes, depending
on their experience,
three to five days.
Using our solution deployed on AgentCore,
we can get it in less than seven minute.
This is a 99% reduction
in the research time
for our network engineer.
We have built the system.
The next question that how
do we evaluate this system.
For evaluation, we are
using a dual approach.
First of all, using an
automated script or framework,
we can easily identify the
consistency and correctness,
but it's also important to
evaluate through human expert
for the accuracy
and whether it's meets
our network engineer,
our network engineer's
expectations or not.
By combining the human
feedback that we have received
and also the value,
it gives us the confidence on
the reliability of the system.
While building this agentic solution,
there are a lot of learnings for us
and let me share the important ones.
It's a perfect timing,
we say, of our AgentCore.
We have been building this
type of specialized agent
for some times
and we reached to a point
where scalability was an issue for us.
When we see AgentCore,
it feels like it's exactly what we needed.
Next is that involve
the domain expert early.
What I mean is that if you are developing
an agentic solution,
my recommendation you
involve your domain expert
from the day one.
For us, the feedback that we
receive from the domain expert
about how our network engineer works,
what are their behaviors,
and what are their pain point
help us to design these
specialized agents.
Third is important of
unifying the knowledge.
When you connect your data
and make a unified knowledge base
from industry standards code base,
your product documentation,
you get a system level understanding
and that overall improve the accuracy
of the answers that you get.
And also, at the same time,
it's remove any ambiguities.
Last but not the least,
infrastructures matters
even more than we think of.
Using AgentCore, our
network engineers focus more
on developing the agentic
structure architect,
agentic structures and as well
as how the agent will behave.
All the heavy lifting is
done by the AgentCore.
As a result,
the development life cycles
improved significantly.
Let me summarize here.
With AgentCore, we have moved beyond
just answering questions.
We have developed a system
that understand how our network
engineers work and think.
And we are excited what comes next.
With that, let me close here
with a perspective from our
organization head, Dag Lindbo.
By unifying the data and the information,
AgentCore let us build specialized agents
that scaled over our tens of
thousands of network engineers.
Thank you.
Over to you, Mark.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks, Sabarshis.
Okay, since I was so great at demo one,
I'll do a quick pass on demo two here.
I'm just gonna kick it off
and not try to click any mouse.
What this is trying to show here
is I get a lot of questions
about how well if I'm
using a coding assistant,
am I able to easily use AgentCore?
And yes, what this is showing you
is a scenario where I've
got an existing REST API,
I've got a URL to it and an API key
and I kicked off a
session with Kiro to say,
take that existing API,
give me a Gateway that
will use that, the MCP,
give me a Strands agent to use that,
and then deploy that agent to the cloud,
write a client, test that client,
and even write a load
test for me and run that.
So here it goes.
So I gave it some context.
I gave it the URL.
I gave it the API key.
Now, it's exploring the
AgentCore command line
to understand what's offered.
It figures out, oh I can do this.
I can create a Gateway.
I see how to do that.
I know I've got access to the API.
So it probes that REST interface,
extracts the OpenAPI spec.
Earlier you saw the swagger
user interface there
describing the API.
It's able to download that.
It pops it into a JSON file,
uploads that to S3,
and now it's ready to create the Gateway.
So, it creates the Gateway.
And here on the left I'm
showing you the actual API spec.
It was able to retrieve that on the fly.
And again, I still haven't
written any lines of code.
I haven't touched any
command lines at all.
I just said, "Hey, go
do this for me please."
And the gateway's already created.
Here, we're just waiting
for the DNS propagation to complete.
It takes about a minute.
So it's got it all set up,
it's got it configured,
and about another 10 seconds
here, it'll be ready.
Once it's ready,
then it's going to add the
API target to the Gateway.
So what is that all about?
It's got to configure an OAuth authorizer.
In this case, I've told
it we should use Kognito.
That's the standard that we
were using in this environment.
It could be whatever you'd like.
And it looks like it's
already done it now,
and now it's on to testing.
So I asked it to test,
given that it's standard MCP,
just use HTTP and do a list tools,
do an invoke tool on any
of the available tools.
And so now, it's got
the Gateway that's API,
sorry, the API is now agent ready.
Now, it's on to testing.
So let's see what happens here.
So it writes a little code
to try to test it out.
Of course, it's going to be successful.
No problem.
You'll see in a moment here
it's going to list the tools.
First, it's getting an access
key from the authorizer.
You've gotta do a secure invocation here
using the MCP protocol.
And voila!
There's all of the tools
automatically coming back as MCP,
even though we started
with just a REST API.
So it's done that mapping.
It's got it live.
You can plug that into any agent.
And here, we tested out invoking a tool.
So we did MCP call tool
on one of the tools
to list customers who was able to do that.
Here it's retrieving the
details on a particular order.
So we've got all of the basics here
of managing orders based on existing APIs
and it's available as MCP now.
So then it's creating
a simple Strands agent
and any of these agent frameworks
makes it easy to just
plug in an MCP server.
So that's what it's doing here.
And in less than a minute here,
it's gonna have a running,
see, it's actually executing right now.
It's actually listing servers,
getting listing orders,
getting order details.
So now the Strands
agent's already working.
We're only a few minutes
into this job here.
I still haven't done any work.
Kind of nice, I like this.
And now what I'd like to do
is deploy it in the cloud.
It's great on my laptop.
I want it in the cloud.
I want to be able to hand it
to app developers and app builders.
And so Kiro says, "Okay,
let me see what it takes."
It checks out the commands.
It figures out all I
need to do is configure
and then launch.
So it does a configure,
configure sees that it's got your agent,
it knows how to just then at that point,
package the code, upload it,
and then create a secure
endpoint for that agent.
So that's what it's doing right now.
It's doing the packaging.
It's getting it uploaded.
It's setting up the endpoint in the cloud.
Another 10 seconds or
so that'll be running.
Once it's running in the cloud, Kiro says,
"Okay, let me test the
agent via the command line."
So we'll do an AgentCore invoke,
prove that it works.
Here it goes right now.
It's doing an invoke,
and let's see if that works.
Hey, what do you know?
It's able to list the customers.
You can get the details
of a particular order.
No problem, it's got session management.
It's secure session isolation.
It can handle those concurrency at scale.
And just to prove that out,
I ask it to write a simple client script
to prove that you can use it from Python,
from boto3 remotely.
And then I had it write a little load test
to spin up a bunch of
sessions concurrently
and prove that that works as well.
So there's a nice little
demo of not writing any code,
taking an existing API,
making it available via Gateway,
writing an agent,
hosting an agent in the cloud,
all with the magic and
wonder of AgentCore.
So let me give you four quick takeaways.
One, business value only comes
when you're in production.
Maybe it's obvious,
but there is that big chasm
and you need to address that
in order to start getting real
value out of these agents.
Second, know what your agents are up to.
Never put an agent in production
if you don't have a good
mechanism for observability.
You need all of the detail there
and you need an easy way
to get access to that.
And then find a way to iterate
and improve your agents,
as well as troubleshoot and debug
when things are going wrong.
Third, security is not optional.
Scale is not optional.
You're not building toys.
You're building production ready agents
to deliver real value.
You've gotta have security
and scale figured out.
And then lastly, don't waste time
crawling around in that chasm.
Use AgentCore and get a smooth
path right over that chasm
from POCs into production ready
real business value.
So with that, here's some resources.
You've got great documentation out there.
Quick starts, tutorials,
we've got workshops, self-service,
or you can use our help with those.
We've got a pretty robust
repo with tutorials as well,
examples of integrations,
A2A, multiple frameworks.
If you're looking to learn
more about agentic AI overall,
this is a skill builder capability.
And then with that, I wanna
thank you all for coming.
Hopefully this is giving you a good idea
of how to cross that chasm
from POC to real production ready agents.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)